la résidence les allées du lac est le
premier projet à être labellisé logement
santé en Île-de-France un label qui
nécessite l'application de plusieurs
règles comme la qualité de l'air la
présence d'équipements sportifs ou
encore la végétalisation des logements
les logements ont aussi été travaillés
de manière avoir des doubles voire
triplle orientation pour qu'on puisse le
ventiler chaque logement un espace
extérieur des cellers des caves enfin de
quoi vraiment à notre sens bien vivre ou
du moins d'être une première étape pour
un bien vivre ensemble la résidence 47
logements locatifs sociaux donct 14
dédiés aux seniors et aux personnes en
situation de handicap et 48 logements en
accession sociale à la propriété dès
leur conception les logements ont été
réfléchis pour favoriser le bien-être
des résidents comment ne pas être
satisfait avec une terrasse comme ça
c'est non on est très satisfait et puis
euh on avait demandé trois pièces on a
eu trois pièces donc ça rentre vraiment
dans dans tout ce qu'on a demandé autre
engagement à respecter le bien vivre
ensemble un employé chargé d' la vie de
la résidence a été engagée des activités
faites par et pour les habitants sont
d'ors et déjà proposé au sein de cette
salle commune nommé la manivelle si on
veut qu'il y ait de l'entraide entre
voisins il faut que les gens se
connaissent et donc c'est important
qu'il y ait un lieu où il puisse se
produire des choses se rencontrer pour
pouvoir s'entraider dans le quotidien la
résidence qui compte 95 logements
affiche déjà complet